511 what do you think yeah thumbs up
thumbs down yeah okay good so I don't
know how many of you would throw in a
little bit when it's it evaluate would
it be in valuing well once you use this
fact over here and substitute you can
you see where I've got three quarters
why three quarters why let me encourage
you to do that by the way when you're
doing this substitution substituted as
it is clearly there's some
simplification that can happen I turn it
into nine over four right there but I
think you're kind of asking for it if
you do that simplification at the same
time as your substitution because what
happens if you make an error and you're
trying to go back and find a where'd I
go wrong if this is your first line that
error is twice as hard to find rather
than this it's like oh I suck you the
wrong thing now I see what I did wrong
you go straight there it's very hard to
locate that debug grade your solutions
gone awry finally where the like oh yes
where did the white go can someone tell
me I cancelled it because can you see on
the knee right up have a common factor
of Y up here just up here and then on
the denominator I also have a common
factor of Y so I've pulled that Y out
and then I just cancel it it's gone and
that's why the wife is okay
ready to move on yes give me a knot yep
okay here we go
so he's my he's my solution I think this
one speaks for itself does anyone have
any questions on number eight yep that's
it say if the absolute value of five
months 13 is smaller smaller than zero
so that that'd be so it's this one yeah
yeah if that was smaller than here then
he would be smaller than five
[Music]
oh I see I see what you're okay all
right hey this is actually really really
good
you confuse me for a second one second
we're done um okay let me just rewind
for a second because maybe in catch
Jake's question and maybe you're gonna
help me and today's question and what's
going on because this is a really
important understand you're gonna go
after Jake he's talking about the fact
that this some I've separated out into
two branches right separate into two
cases each case exists at a particular
time you know when I say the absolute I
of anything it's like sometimes it's
this and sometimes it's that you get a
negative case you get the positive catch
now when you have a look at it I haven't
actually said anything about when it's
one case or when it to the other so the
question is being posed is when I do
this and break it off into this version
of itself right what I'm talking about
is for negative values of this right
when this thing is negative then that's
why I turn it around right that's
actually - outside of five - three - but
if you just evaluate all the minus signs
this is what you end up okay now the
question Jake is ask you great question
is if I'm talking about the negative
version then what does it mean if my
answer is but is this an answer like why
is it an inside if we're talking about
the negative version of the absolute
value can anyone tell me why isn't it
the absolutely company can't be can
shoot
okay so the first thing is I can't move
left to right so you know what I can't
get solutions that are even other spots
that I wouldn't necessarily expect
another good negative yeah okay so
here's the way I would draw it right
five minus three T what does 5 minus 3t
look like if I were to graph this
against a team axis or there's why it's
not X's right I'm not solving for x five
minus three T is going to start from
five it's going to go down really
steeply and then bounce back up okay
like that so this is the thing that I'm
looking at and I'm saying hey wait is it
eight so this solution over here which I
presume is the negative one solution and
then there's a solution over here which
I presume is the the four and a third
solution okay so this is the ship that
muscles been talking about like yeah
look see me over you can get a solution
it's legit I'm going to go ahead and put
it back in it works okay now there's
something else which maybe might help
we've been saying on the thing is
negative therefore should that be right
it's a positive sometimes you aren't
actually supposed to a scooter solution
based on restriction that you have make
sure the thing is though it's not T that
should be negative over here in order to
make this true right this equals this
not when T is negative but when five
minus three T is negative right it's
when this whole thing inside is negative
that you take the other version this guy
right and if you go ahead and you check
this well let's just go do it shall we
sorry just getting a bit of a mess minus
three T is less than negative five so
you divide through it's a negative sign
which means what I'm gonna flip around
that inequality T is over five on three
is that more than five on three
checked out right so that's why this is
the Equality to satisfy which which I
play we do so it's okay and the graph
which I did to draw but I had in my head
okay you guys here with that that's a
good question
okay here we go here's my equality can
you make it happen now what I've done is
I've said okay this original question is
a less than greater than question right
so therefore I'm gonna get a suck of the
number line but what I want to find is
what is that chunk begin and what visit
enter now what I wanted was solving the
equations you're 11 stay with me I
solved the equations that give me those
two boundary points these are not the
solutions to the inequality these just
tell me where the solutions started in
okay now I haven't sent here because
there's a picture in my mind that the
question hasn't asked before so I just
left it in my mind how did I know once I
got that value and that value how did I
know I was between those values and not
on the outside of those match how did I
know that the solution was wasn't this
anyone wouldn't offer a suggestion for
how I knew was the inside not the
outside making
so I did so it's all about the direction
of this right if I were to turn this
around and make it greater than or equal
to then you would get this purple of
solution but I want to push on that a
little more what what is it this way
why would it be the ones between and not
the ones outside yeah yeah yeah yeah
very good so do you see what declan's
done which is so helpful and which I'll
be trying to get you guys to one is to
always see a picture even if you don't
draw if you're not quite at that point
where you can just conjure up the image
in your mind then you just draw
something you know really uh great like
this but it's enough that's enough
there's the picture all absolute value
graphs of a straight line look like this
and you want the bit that's lesser then
the business underneath well that must
be the part that is between the two
values not on the outsides does that
make sense so say with a parabola if I
gave you a parabola over here which we
have in the next page then if you're
lesser then you are on the inside bit
right where is it rewriter than you at
times make sensitive
okay let's not get rid of the wrong
solution
hey baby guy over the page yeah let's do
it
okay we'll do this really really quick
now because we're on this is all just
downhill I want you to a can't believe
at the graph that you're mocking okay I
would tell you this is going to be worth
either sue on three marks this this
graph okay now let's just play pretend
if this one works your marks where do
you think the marks would be I have a
suggestion
okay uh more interesting okay now I
think one of the most important features
is the asymptotes so you can see I've
got my vertical one of my horizontal one
if IB then they've got to be there even
this looks perfect
you've got to show that you know there's
this asymptotes behavior there's one
mark the second mark you mentioned the
on coordinates the second mark would not
be on the corner something much more
basic than that which is just are you in
the right spots in are you the right
shape that's all like that's that's the
basic mark I'm drawing this thing and
waves around in the way that it's
supposed to it's in these quadrants not
these quadrants
okay there's your first mark your second
mark would be the asymptotes yeah
people often people often mix those up
but that's really good
[Music]
that's okay that's we didn't that's
within acceptable because basically it's
just the suit now I said if there were
two marks maybe you want to even write
this okay by the way I don't know how
uncomfortable you feel when I say this
go to work two or three if I was a jerk
I could make up with four okay there's
no hard and fast like people think
method is a lot more objective than it
is there's a lot of subjectivity Jews I
can make this three marks if I want to
look for a particular level of detail
what might be a good third thing that
you think is on here which is important
is now I clued you into this this
morning when we're looking at true
crashed
did you notice you've got me a bucket I
assume you have an axis okay rid of the
excess then get out okay Wow well done
what I'm thinking of is this can you
raise your hand if your paper but
wouldn't your monkey has this on it
anyway a small number hands there what
do we call this guy what's his name I
called it our point for scale okay why
does it matter if I took the point the
scale off if I took that off what's the
big deal what's the problem with that
area
yeah this could be - one of rents it
could but it could be - fifty over X or
minus PI over X or anything scaled
differently okay so that's why the point
it Matt is it hence the name it locks it
into B this particular graph question
you mean doing it like this is this what
you're saying oops
something like this how are you talking
about yes that's fine so what was it's
really clear I see students sometimes
they do this and I know it's kind of
like yes or to get it but yeah no that's
not enough for me because I don't really
know really identifying what that is and
I know what I'm talking about because
I've seen some do that wrong well as
soon as you just put numbers everywhere
you know it's like I'm gonna just go up
to 10 like why it's just that's not the
point okay